[Music]
hi everybody i'm lauren zima we are
backstage the American Idol season
finale just went down and we had a
winner and a love story Maddie's like my
best pal and I've known her since the
beginning of Hollywood week and you know
she she actually happens to be my
girlfriend you and Caleb we learned
tonight aren't dating what had you guys
talked about what would happen if you
wound up in the final two and is this
crazy we thought well if we get to the
final two I I guess we're just gonna
play it by ear but you know we really
wish that this could happen and just
stuff this you know that it happened and
I'm so happy I'm so on top of the world
I can't even believe that this is my
life so it's pretty amazing how did you
handle all these emotions you're in the
final two together which is competitive
how do you handle all that I mean it was
honestly it wasn't as challenging as you
might think
when I looked over at Maddie I was like
I win either way I really do I don't
feel any type of bitter or loss at all
I'm just so happy for her how long has
this been going on January 21st is the
day we met on Hollywood week and it was
the first day of Hollywood week and we
haven't really spent any time apart
since then how did you hide this
relationship well you know it was one of
those things where I didn't want it to
affect anything and I didn't want like
exploit you know my feelings for work
because they're very very real and you
know once the vote was over I was like
shoot I want the world to know hey Liv
are you in love I mean you know I mean
when you remember the date you met
somebody
it sounds kind of serious yeah I
remember I remember looking at her I
knew very quickly is have you written
any songs about Miss Maddie yet you
might just have to buy my next album
[Music]